hey guys it is Friday and for this
week's episode we decided all of us
would be a part of it at the same time
instead of just in between stories so we
hope you like today's format do let us
know what you think but we have 5
stories to get through so we should
probably start what's the what so
there's been a lot of contention over
whether East what's a real sports booth
like for the gaming community who may or
may not be involved in them and then for
obviously the supporting community who
have strong views over whether eSport
it's a real sport but in something that
I think even surprised supporters of
eSports they're actually talking about
having eSports as a part of the 2024
Olympics
yeah competitive gaming got a big shot
in the arm this week the head of Paris's
Olympic Committee spoke to The
Associated Press saying that there are
conversations ongoing with gaming groups
and also the IFC the International
Olympic Committee about adding a gaming
tournament to the Paris games in 2024 so
we don't know a lot about the specifics
yet obviously you know it's just
preliminary preliminary discussions at
this point but definitely a huge move
for eSports whether or not you think
they deserve to be there
the head of Paris's committee said it's
something that they definitely want to
explore considering how popular and have
massive eSports are today like he he
made the case that you know gaming
deserves a shot at the table whether or
not they're accepted remains to be seen
we're gonna not find out the official
program for the games until 2019 or 2020
so still a lot of time left but uh
definitely very exciting news this week
we're all super excited for destiny -
I'm excited
what's up - excited apparently you don't
wonder how I'm in a temper my excitement
I'm gonna go but I'm gonna go buy some
sweet much I thought you would temper
your excitement by not spending a bunch
of money on thank you candy ice trays
that look a lot like penises numbskull
is a design company that is releasing a
bunch of official destiny to merge
everything you can think of they've
pretty much made I'm excited about like
I said the scented candles five scented
candles for five planets all based on
five materials you can find on those
planets spin metal worms for lovely
of course I want a scented candle cold
ones and then I want like my mama
grandma to come over and I'll be like
this is whoops yeah exactly what about
you guys what are you guys able I think
you're forgetting the most important
destiny to a licensing opportunity which
is pop-tarts there's going to be
officially licensed destiny - pop-tarts
don't know for sure what they'll taste
like yet but though it's like a sweet
sweet victory no yeah yeah I think my
couple of favorite things I mean
obviously they're all like keychains and
like bits and pieces that make a little
more sense but there's also bathrobes if
that's something you want there's also
Christmas decorations like bulbuls like
destiny to Global's I guess they must be
the planet I didn't look into it enough
but y'all are probably looking at them
right now so get back to me in the
comments and tell me if the other
planets so I was playing Tacoma
yesterday which is a really bloody great
game that I'm trying to get more people
to play but the point was I was playing
it on Xbox one and I don't play a ton of
Xbox one I'm very much on my PC and then
occasionally on my ps4 boy is the Xbox
one dashboard hard to use for someone
who just wants to pick it up a play yeah
I mean I've made the mistake several
times I'll go to stock quotes and halo 5
will start and I didn't even know I had
high five
it's not his thought Microsoft seems to
have heard out out cries because they're
doing a complete redesign of the whole
menu yeah this week they made the big
announcement that yeah completely
revamping the way the home screen looks
the way the dashboard works the way the
guide works obviously you know huge huge
changes in response to these issues that
they are obviously well aware of since
the launch back in 2013 it's gotten
better over time but still as they add
more features there's more complexity
but now they're kind of stripping those
things back and the first thing you'll
notice when you open up the new home
screen is the last game you played over
the last a be used will be right there
front center so you can jump right back
in if that's what you want to do and if
not there's going to be new things
called content blocks which you can
assign the games or the apps that go in
those sections so whatever you want you
can put there and it's basically just
like a quick launch menu kind of like
folders on PS alright so they're
definitely kind of responding to what
the competition is doing there too
you're also going to be suggestions so
right next to that first game or the
guinea most you played most recently
will be a suggested deal from Xbox Live
or a suggested game or app based on what
you were playing or based on what your
friends were playing so Microsoft's
obviously you know looking at the
feedback and changing the console
hopefully for the better right now you
can if you're a part of the Xbox the
insider program you can test it out
right now and the whole update that
introduces this is coming out later this
year to completely pivot from something
to look forward to you today I got up in
arms this week about something that
they're not looking forward to
microtransactions in shadow of war the
sequel to shadow of Mordor this is an
interesting one we covered it a little
bit earlier this week but it's it's
basically you can pay for loot chests in
this game the and war chests and war
chests there's two different kinds but
they seem to be they're giving you gear
and followers and XP boosts and
everything you get from playing the game
which to me sounds like a shortcut in a
single-player game it's gonna take away
from your your gameplay time yeah I
think that's kind of why people are up
in arms a little bit I mean obviously
this is a single-player game and we're
kind of accustomed to microtransactions
coming in the form of you know cosmetics
things that don't actually change the
gameplay experience but you know this is
this is a full-price game that's coming
out and it's offering you you know the
opportunity to level and pick up cool
followers and and earn yourself cool
gear but instead this this whole system
where you can just buy it and I think
people are really confused by that and I
think the reason why people are angry is
they're angry about what this might mean
going forward they're like we're all
microtransactions going if they're you
know it's starting to be so heavily
implemented into a triple-a single play
space I mean microtransactions I think
it's worth saying or you know not new
I think the exception here or the
difference here is like you guys were
saying single-player game brings up the
question of why would you want to do
that at the same time though they are
completely optional everything you can
earn you can earn through
normal gameplay as well it's you know
you do you its 2017 it's this is where
games are but it is a very interesting
precedent that it may be setting here
obviously you know the game doesn't come
out until October so remains to be seen
how this all works in the live game
scenario and we don't know the prices
yet it's interesting as well because it
was obviously something that they
anticipated because they released this
information late on Friday in a forum
post in a forum post it wasn't even a
traditional press release or anything
that would out really on their social
channels or nothing that they really
wanted to call attention to so they kind
of you get the idea you get the
understanding that they saw it as kind
of a tricky optics situation they didn't
know how it was gonna look so they kind
of put it out there on a Friday when
maybe a lot of people wouldn't see it I
think it's also worth learning
Assassin's Creed unity also had
microtransactions in single-player where
you would come across chests that you
couldn't open unless you like before I'm
pretty sure it was special keys like
what yeah you had to buy like a special
keys or whatever with real money to
access chests that you could find in the
game so this isn't the first time
something like this has happened and I
think people are just worried that
microtransactions are already extra
money on top of how expensive games are
nowadays and you know you want to be
able to pay a certain amount of money
and feel like you're getting the full
experience and anything that seems to be
invading on that I think is what's
boring game
another huge piece of news this week was
around the new ps4 game from Ninja
Theory hell-blade there is a very
controversial permadeath situation going
on so fluid situation we don't exactly
know all the specifics at this point but
it looks like when you get to a certain
point if you meet certain parameters the
game will essentially reset and make you
start again which is causing a bit of an
uproar yes sir - what's the very
beginning of the game um cinema the
protagonist gets infected with rot and
apparently in the game lets you know
that every time you fail okay every time
you die the rot will spread and if the
rot reaches her head then the game says
you will lose all your progress comes up
in massive letters it's impossible to
miss it's not a conversation it's
something the game is telling
so I think that's why you know all the
review was definitely calling it out
like dis appears to be quite serious
permadeath that said pc gaming site pc
gamers and looked into it and they died
like 50 times on purpose and did not
experience the perma death in response
to that people said no no the deal is
you have to die multiple times over
multiple check points of course the game
has multiple chapters there are people
who come out saying they did experience
permadeath but a lot of those reports
that come through places like near gap
that can't be completely confirmed yeah
I don't think anyone has come out with
like a screen or a video showing hey I
actually experienced perma death so it's
probably not something you definitely
need to worry about but it's definitely
caused an uproar it's interesting to me
when a game from Ninja Theory who are so
much about their narrative all their
games are always about the story that
they would put into something like an
element like this to make you replay
parts of the story that you've already
played because not only if you lose all
your progress and you start again you
gonna be annoyed but you're gonna just
like not pay attention to that story
they're trying to tell and then when you
push past it you're just gonna kind of
be annoyed well the thing is I think I
think that's entirely the point so I
think they want you to be scared of
permadeath because the entire game is
about you know her she's enduring all
these like psychoses and she's basically
got PTSD the game has a huge focus on
mental health so I think putting the
fear of permadeath in the player makes
their position quite similar to sinless
and it makes it easier to empathize with
her because the tension is there for
both of you so even if it is a bluff I
personally think it's a pretty clever
one and I think if it was a thing that
actually happened it would be very silly
because no one wants to lose six hours
of progress but to make people scared
and to make people actually feel like
every combat encounter is a threat much
like she does in the game is cool that's
everything we have for you this week
we're all done and if you want to hear
more about Hell blade you can check out
our review on site you can also see
reboot and a history of Sunday we've got
a video is 50 50 minutes long about all
sonic games should definitely check that
out it's really cool yes
do let us know what you thought of
today's stories how you like this format
this talkie-talkie format we like it so
we want to know what you think of it we
will see you again on Monday with more
news but in the meantime be sure to have
yourselves a great weekend Dan's already
got a Jedi bathroom say I do as its a
Jedi Road you can just say Road when a
Jedi wears it it's a road okay but you
on to Jedi's so it's about that anyway
moving on this also Christmas
decorations like bulbuls like destiny to
bubbles